[Music]
hello everyone
so uh today we'll
we'll start discussing a a new topic
within the kinematics chapter
so it's called
rigid body rotation
so from the name of it it may seem like
this is this is a topic which should
come within the purview of the subject
dynamics
but but as we'll see it is very much a
part of mechanics of solids
so in order to motivate the discussion
for this rigid body rotation uh what we
have to do is uh
we have to uh go back
to the slide of one of the earlier
lectures
so i want you to bring i want to bring
your attention back
to this particular formula that we had
arrived at earlier
so this was
within the topic of quantification of
deformation
so one of the earliest parts of the
lectures
so we'll write this down again and
proceed from there
what we have is the d small x vector
is equal to the capital x vector plus
the capital x vector dotted with the
gradient operator and that
operating on the displacement vector
now for our current current purpose
it will find it useful to
write the equivalent index notation
of this particular equation so the left
hand side of this is very easy
this is just that this small x vector
which can be simply written
as d x i
similarly the first term is also very
easy to write
like this now for this last term let me
just write it down and then i'll discuss
so i'll write it as d x j
del u i del x j
so you see here earlier in that let me
go back to that earlier slide once more
if you see here i had put this bracket
here so
this dx vector dotted with the gradient
operator
that was like a scalar operator this was
like a vector the gradient operator is
also like a vector
and we have a dot product between these
two things so it is
like a scalar so
you see if you just for a moment forget
about this
ui it is as if this dxj
it is clubbed with this del del xj
so because
the index j is repeated here
what you basically have for this is
d x 1 del del x 1 plus d
x 2 del del x 2 plus d x 3
delta x 3 that entire operator
operating on this ui so
uh you can think of it like this
dxj del xj
that is equivalent to dx1
delta x1 plus dx2
delta x2 plus dx3
[Music]
delta x 3 and that is
exactly equivalent to
e x vector sorted with the gradient
operator
okay so we understand that whatever we
had obtained
earlier in our quantification of
deformation topic
this is the equivalence statement so why
are we right writing like this what is
the advantage
well i will see in a moment that because
we have this thing now
del u i del xj and if you now
shift your focus just to this partial
derivative
just to this partial derivative here del
u y del xj
then uh again i am writing this
in my right hand column the del ui
del xj
you see if you just look at it at this
thing it how many free
indices does it have i and j so there
are two
free indices correspondingly we can
conclude that
this is a tensor of order two and
because it is a tensor of order two
it can be very well be represented
as a 3 into 3 matrix
now you know from your first year
studies
of matrices that
if you have any matrix that can be
represented
as the sum of the symmetric and the
anti-symmetric parts
and we'll do exactly that here that kind
of a decomposition here
by writing this as exi first term
remains unchanged
and for the second term i'll write the
dxj as it is
but this del ui del xj what i will do is
i will decompose
in this fashion del uy del xj
plus del uj
del x i this is the first part
and
i will adjust whatever i have added
extra in the previous line
by writing this thing
so you see what i have done here
whatever the the del ui del xj was here
that is actually uh broken up into this
half del u y del x j
this half delight del x j together these
two make up this
but here i have added this del u j del x
i to either with the half extra
and here i have adjusted that with the
minus half delu j del x i
so this line here is exactly equal to
whatever
was present in the earlier line now you
see
this particular combination the del u by
del
with the half the half del u by del x j
plus del u j del x i
that we have already uh
we've come across this particular term
earlier and what was that
we just look back
you see half del u y del x j
plus del u j del x i that we had chosen
to define as the
infinitesimal strain tensor so that is
exactly the term that we have
encountered right now so
we recognize that half del ui
del xj plus del u j
del x i is nothing but the strain tensor
it is the strain tensor itself
and when i write the strain tensor i
implicitly mean that it is the
infinitesimal strain tensor or the small
strain tensor
the other part here this one
the half del ui
del xj minus del
u j del x i
this part is referred to as the rotation
tensor
it is as if uh
this entire thing is somehow denoting
the rotation
so uh before we can uh discuss anything
uh anything further on the rotation
tensor i would
i i'd like you to note down that
uh corresponding to this little
discussion we had
about the del ui del xj being a 3 into 3
matrix
and that being decomposed into the
symmetric and the anti-symmetric part
that is exactly what we have managed to
do here because
this thing is symmetric
it is symmetric because you can
interchange the i and j
and it would not make any difference you
can see here if you interchange
if you if you replace the i by the j and
the j by the i
so this entire and here also if you
replace the j by the i
and the i by the j this entire term
remains unchanged
however this part if you replace the i
by the j
and the j by the i here similarly if you
replace the j by the i
the i by the j then this the whatever
the resulting term is
that is the negative of this thing
because you will have del u j del x i
minus del u y del x and that is a
negative of what i have written here
so this part is the antisymmetric part
so that is what i meant here so any
three into three matrix
can be subdivided or decomposed into
this into its symmetric part
and its anti-symmetric part and it is
nothing special with the del ui del fc
if you have any matrix like say
a having three rows and three columns
you can have this kind of a
decomposition
all right so what we are saying is that
from this del u by del x
g the symmetric part it is giving us the
strain tensor the infinitesimal or the
small strain tensor
and the anti-symmetric part of the del u
by del xj
that is giving us the rotation tensor
this is very very important i repeat
because it is so very important that the
symmetric part of the del ui del xj
that gives me the strain tensor and the
anti-symmetric part of the daily white
lxj
that gives me the rotation tensor okay
now uh
we go to the next slide and we note down
that this rotation tensor usually it is
denoted by the
capital greek letter omega so
the rotation tensor
so this is the capital omega symbol
now based on this
what we can do is we can quickly go back
to this earlier equation
to this equation that we had written
earlier
and we can write this in terms of the
epsilon and the omega
so we can d
small x i is equal to d capital x i plus
d x j
epsilon i j plus d
x j capital omega
i j before proceeding any further
as i had mentioned in one of the earlier
lectures uh we must always
whenever we write anything new in index
notation uh it is important that we
should
check with the consistency of the order
of the tenses
on the left hand side we have just one
free index which means there is a vector
or a tensor of order one this here also
one free index same index i as in the
left hand side
so very much consistent with whatever we
have here and this also is a vector or
tensor of order one
now this entire entity whatever it may
mean physically
but at least mathematically speaking we
are very sure
that since the j is a repeated index
here and we have only one free index i
this entire term ultimately is just a
tensor of order one because there is
only
one free index similarly for this
third term on the right hand side we
have j to be repeated
and we have only one free index i so
this entire
term whatever it may mean physically
there is no doubt that
mathematically speaking this is a tensor
of order
1 and it is also denoted by the single
free index
i so everywhere the free index is given
by i
and this entire equation is very much
consistent mathematically
okay now
what we want to do is uh we want to see
explicitly
about this omega i j
it is
[Music]
is this but in terms of
the matrix representation what does it
look like
so
before i write anything down i want you
to think for a moment
uh about what could possibly be
the diagonal elements of this matrix
representation of this equivalent matrix
representation for the
rotation tensor so we have already noted
that the omega i j
the rotation tensor is anti-symmetric
if you have an anti-symmetric matrix
then by definition the diagonal elements
must turn out to be zero and you can
verify that yourself
so what we can say uh here is
or what we can write down explicitly
here is that
no matter what happens to the off
diagonal terms the diagonal terms must
be zero
so this is like this
[Music]
[Music]
okay now
note that this is a
this is an anti-symmetric matrix so this
term here
in the second row and the first column
should be the negative of what is
present in the first row
second column so
this should be
the diagonal element is 0 and
this one
should simply be del u to del x 3 minus
del u 3 del x 2
and finally for the third row uh
we know that it should be the negative
of this first row
third column so this should be minus
del ui del x3
minus del u3 del x1
and this term here that i'm going to
write in the third row second column
should be the negative of the second row
third column which is this term
it should be minus half del
u2 del x3 minus
del u3 del x2 and the diagonal element
the third row third column element
should be zero
now you note one very interesting thing
if you just discount this negative sign
then in terms of independent entities
how many of them are there
in this matrix see this 0 is there
of course but this is the negative of
this
this is this one is the negative of this
and this one is the negative of this
so among the non-zero elements we have
basically just three independent
elements
so even though this is a three into
three matrix and
it is the math equivalent matrix
representation
of the second order tensor but
effectively
in terms of the actual entities there
are only
three of them present here this one
this one and this one and we can exploit
this fact
to write it
in a slightly more clean fashion like
this
0 minus omega 3
omega 2 omega
3 uh so when i'm seeing omega this time
i mean the on the small greek letter
omega
so this is the capital greek letter
omega this is the small greek letter
omega
this is minus sorry this is zero
this is minus omega 1 this is
minus omega 2
this is 0 there is no hard and fast rule
as to why i am choosing this to be minus
and this to be like this but
this is generally adopted for some sort
of convenience
you'll see in a moment but you see
what i what i'm basically writing this
is that this minus omega 3 is equal to
this thing my this omega 2 is equal to
this thing
and the minus omega 1 is equal to this
thing and the rest of it is just
following from there
now uh what is the advantage
of writing like this one advantage is
that we can explicitly recognize the
fact that we need only three independent
elements
uh non-zero elements the omega 1 omega 2
and omega 3
to denote this 3 into 3 matrix now
because there is
this kind of uh of
only three element uh picture
uh it perhaps gives us the an indication
that
maybe it should be possible to somehow
represent this kind of a three into
three matrix
uh in in another form maybe perhaps
using vectors
which actually involves only three uh
three independent quantities
okay so uh so how can you perhaps do
that
so in order to do that we go to the next
slide
but before going to the next slide uh
what what i want to do is
i i want to
proceed uh towards a direction
which will help me to
motivate this kind um an explanation
for or why this this entire thing
is perhaps referred to as the rotation
tensor
why the name rotation i mean for the
other one we are calling it a string
uh why uh why this is rotation
specifically
okay so let me go to the next slide try
to motivate that discussion
so we have this equation d x i is equal
to d
capital x i plus d x j
epsilon i j i am just repeating what i
had written in the previous slide
and capital omega i j now you consider a
special case
consider the special case
when epsilon i j the strain tensor
is perfectly equal to zero so there is
we are saying that there is no strain
in the body if there is no strain in the
body
then uh forget the mass
if i just tell you that there is no
strain in the body
then what should be your immediate
conclusion your immediate conclusion
should be that
perhaps if there is no strain then
perhaps no
uh no deformation is taking place within
the body
but if there is no deformation taking
place within the body
does it prevent us from
saying that there should not be any uh
any translation or rigid body
rotation it does not like if you if i
so so
let me give you a physical example
okay so i have this
pin here which i am using to write on my
pen tablet
now this is fairly a rigid body
now i am holding it like this and
suppose i rotate it like this
this is a simple rotation simple
rotation like this
i can also rotate it like that i can do
various things
i can not rotate it and just move it
like this a simple translation
but i'm choosing to rotate it like this
now when i'm doing this
you can understand that two points which
are present in this body
they are not moving relative to each
other this is very very important to
note
so you have one point here and one point
here
they are not moving relative to each
other when i am moving the entire body
or rotating the entire body like this
so this is the kind of physical scenario
where i am saying
that there is no strain present within
the pen
so there is no strain present anywhere
within this
pen when i am moving it but the fact
remains
that i am actually moving it so there is
displacement
displacement is not zero but the strain
is zero this is very very important to
note
okay so if we go back to our
uh our discussion
so this is what i mean by this epsilon i
t equal to zero so under this special
consideration
i have just this
[Music]
all right now i've already seen that the
capital omega i j in the previous slide
that can be represented by this kind of
a three into three matrix having
effectively just three independent
elements and this is where it gets
interesting
you see uh
this thing here it is
just one um it is
uh it is like one repeated index here so
some kind of tensor operation is going
on here
okay however whatever is going on here
uh it can be equivalently represented
in a slightly different fashion in this
way
i'm falling back on the vector
representation again
plus okay
so this is the trick part so here i will
write
the omega factor i'll just explain it in
a moment
and this is the vector cross product
with dx vector
so this is x this is my x
and this is the vector cross product
so what i'm saying is
whatever you have from here whatever you
have from here
that can so you first of all you
understand that there is a vector here
there is a vector here no problem
the cross the vector cross product of
two vectors that should be a vector
there should not be any doubt about it
you all know this
in the previous line also we have
already concluded
that whatever this entity is
mathematically it should be a tensor of
order one
and a tensor of order one we know that
should be that is nothing but a
vector so as far as the consistency of
the order of the tensors is there
these two are perfectly fine question is
whether they're equal or not we'll come
to that
but you just note that this is a vector
and this also is a vector that much is
okay
it is also very nice to see that we have
the dxj
vector here that is also somehow present
here the question is
what is going on with this little trick
here
so uh you can actually verify this
long hand i am not going to do the long
long hand thing
i'll just uh ask you to do this here by
noting that
the omega vector that we understand
to be equal to this thing
omega 1 omega 2 and
omega 3. this column vector
in matrix representation and you all
know this
the dx vector the equivalent matrix
representation is nothing but
dx1 dx2 and dx3
now uh so somebody very clever
figured out that if you can actually do
the vector multiplication of these two
things
the resulting entity is exactly the same
if you if you do the the complete
expansion
of this term noting of course that
ah sorry so noting of course that the
omega ij
contains terms like this you can
actually do it
so
if we uh go back to our slide here the
way that you can actually verify this
is you can substitute uh or you can just
repeat
the j uh here with uh
in this form dx1 omega i1
plus dx2 omega i2 plus dx3
omega i3 and then
you can actually put different values of
this i as
1 2 and three now you'll have three
components there
similarly you can expand this out using
your high school mathematics
uh you can carry out the cross product
and you will finally see
that whatever you are obtaining here and
whatever you're obtaining here
will be exactly equal okay i won't spend
any
any more further time on this rather
i'll try to
see if i can motivate a physical
interpretation of this
so first of all you note that we are
working under the special condition
consideration that epsilon i j is equal
to zero so the strain is zero
when the strain is zero and you are
ending up with this sort of an
expression
you note that this vector quantity
whatever
it is it is perpendicular
to this as well as it is perpendicular
to this
i repeat suppose you have any any vector
cross product like a cross b
you know that the resulting entity must
be perpendicular to the both the
original vectors so it must be
perpendicular to this
it must be perpendicular to this so the
result of this
okay so whatever this thing is it is
perpendicular
we understand that this is perpendicular
to a dx vector
okay now uh
let me just write that down that
the vector
[Music]
must be
perpendicular to the dx vector itself
now furthermore uh you
you understand that because we are
operating under
small deformations uh
suppose we unders we understand that
this
magnitude of this omega vector
if this and
this both these magnitudes
are small
this is a very important and it's a very
short statement but it's a very powerful
line that we're going to write
if both the magnitudes of this vector
and this vector
are small then
we can understand that the magnitude
of this this quantity this vector
that must be also small
okay now
if this is true
then can we not conclude
[Music]
that dx vector
is almost equal to
the d capital x vector
so think for a moment about what we have
just what we have concluded
first of all we started with epsilon i j
equal to zero
so we are working under no string
then we are saying that we have we have
we are managing to write it like this
and because overall the deformations are
small then
omega this omega cross dx term must be
small
and from that we are concluding that the
[Music]
the the distance or the relative
the the difference in the position
vectors of two neighboring points
in the deformed state that is what is
meant by this d small x vector
that must be almost equal to or
approximately equal to
whatever the thing or whatever the the
relative
uh position vector was between two
neighboring points in the undeformed
state and
that is exactly what is meant by rigid
body
motion but this has of course been
brought about
by uh by the rotation of this thing
omega and we are saying that it is the
rotation because
it is perpendicular to the
to the the position vector connecting to
neighboring points
so if we have the
[Music]
undeformed state like this you remember
that we had taken our point p
here and the point q here and
this vector between them that was
our d x vector because
this position vector was x vector and
this was
x plus d x vector that we had written
one in one of the earliest classes so
this
uh relative uh vector
from p to q that is dx vector and we are
seeing that the
overall motion or overall displacement
is such
brought about through this omega that it
is perpendicular to this
dx vector and that is why
it is like a rotation so you have this
kind of a thing and it's just rotating
about like that so as a result of this
special kind of displacement
together with the fact that the epsilon
ig is equal to zero we have
this kind of a thing that the relative
motion between
or the relative displacement even in the
undeformed state
that doesn't change all right
so this this was a fairly long lecture
but we have completed this particular
topic on rigid body
rotation in one shot and
in the next one we'll go to a very very
important topic
in the next part of the lecture go to a
very important topic principle strains
thank you very much